So as we get into the middle of the week this
week, we are now really just five weeks from
the start of the first early ballots and absentee
ballots in various states.
So I want to have sort of like a very sober
conversation with you so that we don't all
end up surprised and devastated on November
4th if Donald Trump wins.
We would obviously still be devastated.
But I don't want us to be surprised, despite
all of the polling that we've been looking
at, these great polls for Joe Biden in states
nationally, etc., and we'll look at some of
them later.
Donald Trump can still win reelection here.
When you look at the historical precedent,
it looks really bad for Trump.
When you look at being 100 days out in past
elections, no incumbent has been reelected
with this level of disapproval, combined with
the level of chaos in our country and in our
economy, like it looks historically disastrous
for Donald Trump.
Trump can't get past 40 percent approval.
Two thirds of the country thinks corona virus
is getting worse.
Unemployment is at 11 percent.
Trump is underwater in just about every battleground
state.
Trump is mishandling the three most important
issues to voters today.
Voters say the most important issues are corona
virus, economy and race relations.
And they prefer Biden over Trump to different
degrees on those three issues.
And yet Trump can win.
Now, of course, we all know there could be
a so-called October surprise.
And a lot of the questions I get about how
Trump could win are what kind of October surprise
could turn it around.
OK, we get a cure and vaccine and Trump takes
credit for it and some people fall for it.
Maybe Trump lies about coronavirus numbers
to justify reopening the economy and the economy
improves even if temporarily.
And Trump gets credit, takes credit.
OK, you know, Trump cures cancer or something
like that.
Trump goes to war either with another country
or with law enforcement in Portland or Chicago,
as we are seeing.
But the thing is, we don't actually even need
a so-called October surprise for Donald Trump
to win.
What can happen has a lot to do with us and
a lot to do with Donald Trump.
So on their side, continued anger at.
The way Trump has been treated, Trump has
argued he's the victim, he's just treated
so terribly.
And some people will fall for it and they
could actually say, I'm going to turn out
because Trump has been treated so unfairly
only in some of those close key states.
And Trump katik this out.
I'm talking places like North Carolina, Pennsylvania,
Florida, places where there's certainly a
lead for Biden right now, but not necessarily
an overwhelming one.
Then add to that that the polling could be
slightly too favorable to Joe Biden.
So this is not the polls are wrong, but imagine
that the margin of error, which is there for
a reason, skews towards Donald Trump.
So when Biden is plus four, he's really plus
one right now.
So if Biden's really plus one, you don't need
that much for it to be a Trump win by a small
margin like we saw in a bunch of states in
2016 when Biden is plus three right now, maybe
that's really a tie.
And that could push this even closer.
And then the left could do self-inflicted
damage to itself.
I talked yesterday about, you know, let's
postpone some of the policy disagreements
that don't make a difference right now until
after the election.
Let's focus on winning.
As an example, I mentioned the debate between
Medicare for all and a public option, important
debate, significant debate, so important to
so many people's lives.
But in the next three months, it doesn't do
anything for us.
Biden is not in favor of Medicare for all.
Most Senate Democrats aren't in favor of it.
And with Trump, we're not getting either Medicare
for all nor the public option.
So what's the point of debating that for the
next three months when the focus should be
get out the vote?
The most important thing we can do is run
as if we're three points behind.
I'm sorry.
Run as if we're 10 points behind.
But vote as if our vote could decide the states
in which we are voting.
I know my vote's not going to decide Massachusetts,
but I'm operating in the mindset of my vote
is as important as it would be.
I'm taking it as seriously as I would if Massachusetts
could go one vote to Trump or by one vote
to Joe Biden.
If we all actually do this, we could end up
with a historic rebuke of the Republican Party,
not just the White House, but also the Senate.
If we don't, the devastation on November 4th
is going to be overwhelming.
Vote early, vote absentee if you can.
I've already requested my absentee ballot.
Consider the betting Web sites, which generally
tend to give Joe Biden about a 60 percent
chance of winning right now.
Remember, Hillary on many Web sites had a
70 percent chance in 2016 and she lost.
So Joe Biden having 60 percent means Trump
has 40 percent.
Those aren't great odds for anybody to decide
to stay home.
If when I see those numbers, I don't say I'll
sit back and be an observer here.
No, I'll be a participant.
So the messages Trump can win.
Trump can win.
No complacency, no smugness or satisfaction
from the polling data.
The polling data is a signal that tells us
we have an opportunity.
That's the way I see it.
North Carolina looks like it's Biden plus
seven.
I'll talk about that later.
That means Biden has an opportunity in North
Carolina.
That's the way we read the polling until Election
Day.
That's all the polling tells us, which is
why this has to be the message until November
3rd.
Let me know your thoughts on Twitter at David
Pakman.
We will take a very short break and be
right back.